[Music]
as I played Rainbow six siege for the
first time recently
one question crossed my mind why did it
take me two years to try this at this
point I've been hooked for weeks I
practiced as often as I can
I returned time and time again to this
complex and rewarding shooter and I'm
still finding reasons to love it it's a
marvel of modern game design upon
further investigation I discovered I was
not at all the only one since its launch
in December 2015
it has tripled its total player base
accumulating 25 million users in all 2.3
million of them play it every day for
comparison blizzards overwatch one of
the more successful multiplayer games on
the market has a little more than 30
million players
Rainbow six isn't that far behind its
community is not just alive but thriving
with memes and in jokes of its own
centered around some of the more
endearing ly useless playable characters
[Music]
honey there's nothing to fear
I think siege flew under the radar for a
while because of several reasons first
off it's worth noting that there wasn't
much height building up to its release
in fact many actively resented Rainbow
six siege because in 2011 Ubisoft showed
off Rainbow six Patriots promising a
story-driven morally complex shooter
with single-player potential when the
publisher announced the shift to a
multiplayer based experience in 2014 it
rubbed many people the wrong way seed
was fighting an uphill battle before it
even released secondly its aesthetic
doesn't do it many favors while the
Kevlar padding and riot shields are
appealing for people who prefer the
military look they don't really convey
what the game actually is a hero shooter
if you took overwatch made it ten times
harder more punishing and focused
largely on close quarters combat with
destructible environments you kind of
have Rainbow six siege lastly there's
the unfortunate story of the game's
launch server issues plagued its first
few weeks while a thin supply of maps
and characters meant it was widely
overlooked it had the skeleton of a
great game but it's bones were brittle
and almost ready to break but here's the
thing Ubisoft Montreal didn't give up it
rolled out patches and updates bug fixes
and server maintenance it promised a
year of content that would add new
characters and maps throughout the
coming months little by little it's Mia
culpa won fans back it became one of
Triple A games weirdest anomalies and
one of the greatest comeback stories in
the medium that's largely because
Ubisoft Montreal listened to fans in
numerous updates on its blog the company
outlined the roadmap for the year's
content it gave the usual patch notes
but also detailed exactly how those
updates would meet player feedback after
steadily building its player base during
2016
Ubisoft continued through 2017 as well
and as of this video has plans for the
entirety of next year - boo
[Music]
in a day and age when games are designed
to have longer lifespans offering
players continual content throughout the
years after release Rainbow six siege
puts Titans such as destiny - and the
division to absolute shame it releases
new characters and maps with one season
of content and continues to balance the
changes well into the next Ubisoft even
postponed a whole season to make way for
operation health a maintenance period
reviled by some fans but in the long
term still a sign of goodwill on
Ubisoft's part it's also worth noting
that all of this content releases for
free yes you can spend real-world money
on specific cosmetic items and to boost
the unlock rate of new characters siege
also provides an array of bonuses for
buying a $30 yearly pass but unlike
games such as Battlefront 2 or a
fortnight Rainbow six siege doesn't feel
built around this progression system at
all it is a deep intricate game with
potential for thousands of hours of
playtime at no additional cost a common
complaint with destiny or the division
another Ubisoft published title is that
the games themselves aren't all that fun
on their own they rely mainly on their
progression aspects to keep players
hooked when they don't have solid
mission and level design as a foundation
to start from people take notice they
get bored they play other games this may
sound obvious but I think a huge reason
see just thriving is because it is a
thrilling game in itself it's deep
complex unforgiving rewarding and
exhilarating over the course of one
match I can honestly say that I would
still come back to siege even if it
didn't have unlocks and progression
options I could not say the same for
destiny to the division or battlefront
to siege takes time to learn and after
150 hours I'm nowhere near seeing every
possible permutation of the map's
operators and tactical possibilities at
play with 18 offensive characters 18
defensive operators and most importantly
no respawns every little action could
mean eventual victory or sudden doom
take this match for example I'm using
Valkyrie the Navy SEAL known for her
portable cameras that the defensive team
can cycle through on their viewing
devices at first I placed the cameras on
walls and ceilings at vital choke points
as the match continues however a
teammate shows me something new
I can shred the upper part of a wall
toss one of my cameras into the gap and
now I can see two full rooms with no
sheetrock in the way I doubled my field
of view with a trick I never considered
before of course in this match it didn't
really help me because my teammates shot
me square in the face but anyway it was
a cool trick regardless here's a bigger
picture example one of my favorite
operators IQ uses a device that can scan
for electronic objects through walls
floors and ceilings it's super useful
against characters such as Jaeger and
bandit heroes with defensive gadgets
that make life harder for any attacking
team but on house a map set in a serene
suburb IQ scanning device becomes even
more useful most of the walls floors and
ceilings are made of wood and so you can
destroy defensive objects easier with
bullet penetration by gauging the
scenario selecting the right operator
and using her device to the fullest I
helped my team to a tense victory and in
a game that almost demands communication
among teammates Rainbow six siege has a
community that's oddly willing to
embrace newcomers
there are definitely elitist players who
look down on newbies but I've also seen
countless videos of people being guided
through their first few matches learning
the ins and outs of environmental
destruction and bomb defusal now here's
the best part of all this and I think
this is the secret to why Rainbow six
siege continues to grow if you started
playing siege today it would not feel
like a two-year old title the game has
been continually updated to remain
relevant it has a welcoming community
willing to teach newcomers and there are
millions of other rookies also going
through the same learning process as you
we live in a time when games are often
more concerned with being platforms than
discrete experiences destiny warframe
and overwatch all follow this ethos but
for a game to truly pull it off
despite its mediocre start is something
truly amazing to see I could go on
forever but I just want to say that I
think Rainbow six siege is the
culmination of many things I love about
modern games it has a diverse cast a
thriving community and it's built for
emergent situations like the ones I
mentioned above it's one of those games
where you keep discovering uncharted
depths of
time you play it's been a long road
since it's shaky launch but now there's
no question Rainbow six siege is here to
stay